scp-682 vs dr bright could this battle  of the immortals finally result in one  of their lives coming to an end let's  find out the plan was to get scp-682 to  ingest dr bright's  scp-963 medallion erasing the beast's  consciousness and replacing it with the  good doctors from there it would  hopefully be a little more cooperative  with attempts to kill it but it didn't  quite work out like that dr bright's  consciousness was at war with the  monsters inside its body after eating  the medallion on the outside 682 grew  giant claws and tunneled out of the  chamber where it ate the feet of one  researcher dr samet thankfully dr bright  was able to escape with his life and  inhabit a new human body but fragments  of his consciousness were left in 682's  malicious brain